so you put into this medically induced
coma can you
take us through what happened next i
woke up in singapore and i had a
full-time job
lived in an apartment similar to this in
singapore can remember the colour of the
shower
the registration plate on my car the
suits i used to wear to work and i ran a
sales team that sold virtual reality
games and i did that for two years
is this common for people that are
induced comas to live another life
i'm still not sure today that whether
that was something else
or whether that was simply my mind
keeping me
super busy while the doctors had the
chance to fix me that's
that's probably the most powerful thing
that's ever ever happened to me that
absolute feeling of this is your second
chance
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
the dubai cast 25th floor of the marina
it's not a bad place to do a podcast is
it not at all mr paul evans welcome to
the show how are you good i'm good mate
i'm good very glad to have you thanks
for having me on
in your town i'm not sure it's my town
but yeah it's my yeah it's my home
that's most certainly uh it's your flat
my home
nick's flat my podcast studio
your town my
so we're going to go through a lot today
but where do we start
where does the genesis of your story in
terms of making you who you are today
where does that begin
um probably begins somewhere around the
age of 13 or 14 when
i was a a troubled little school kid who
was
extremely misunderstood and um and
considered to be
quite stupid and then the relentless
journey to prove all those teachers
wrong
which at 45 years old i'm still trying
to do today i guess that's still in the
source code definite motivation there
for that yeah
even today even though probably all
those teachers have rest their souls
have passed on and
there wouldn't be one of them i can say
look i told you i was gonna be somebody
so that's something i was considering
thinking about this last night that
what happens to you as a child lays down
foundations
infinitely for the rest of your life and
i think that there's a
really interesting implication for
bullying there because
bullies maybe they get some recompense
in the time maybe they've got to do some
detention maybe they've got to do
whatever
but consistent bullying throughout
school which is something that i
dealt with as well
it sets a tone for the bully ease
life the victim's life for the rest of
their days unless they do an ungodly
amount of deprogramming and self-work
and well they use it to motivate
themselves in the right manner
so i would imagine that you're the size
you are and you have the ability to
train like you do
and you build yourself into a human that
can't be bullied
because you didn't enjoy being bullied
and then i would imagine that also
you'll have personality traits
that when you see whatever the bullying
may be obviously in
later life it's a different style of
bully but if you see somebody being
bullied today you'll be the first guy to
step forward and say behave yourself
it makes me it makes me very very very
uncomfortable it's one of the few things
that i'm incredibly passionate about
yeah
when you watch individuals bully or be
bullied
whether it's in the workplace whether
it's in a venue on a night
experience i'm also the same i
absolutely love it
i loathe teachable bullies who are
bullying my children at the moment
through their
authoritarian manners when i see people
in our venues
trying to dominate other customers it's
uh
yeah it's in my dna that i don't
tolerate that and i don't like it
i'll stand in front of anybody i see
being bullied and
i try to create an environment in our um
in our company today that is
is absolutely the opposite way you know
bullying can be
perceived from multiple angles whether
it's a senior
colleague bullying down the track i
can't have that i can't stand it
and that all stems from being you know
kicked around the school playground when
i was 12 and 13 i guess so what did that
move into bullying at school and then
where did you go after that
um bullying in school projected itself
from there
into bullying from kids from being from
a different town as a liverpool fan
going to manchester school
and being bullied by teachers you know
it's a different style of bullying but
asking a dyslexic schoolboy to stand up
on it in front of his entire class and
spell words in front of teachers is
bullying just
no doubt about that um unfortunately
that then projected itself into
my work life where i became pretty good
at what i could do
and then i became an arrogant prick who
just decided to
nobody anybody that got in the way on my
journey to become
successful i would walk through i wasn't
a bully but i didn't i didn't consider
people's opinions
or people's feelings or people's um
projection of how i was being to be
concerning for me
um because success became way more
important than personal perception
but i didn't know what success was then
i was just a 22 23 year old kid
thinking that success was a paycheck at
the end of the month how did you
define success money
money growth progression possession
22 23 years of age what did you learn
working for jack welsh
the best ten percent get promoted the
bottom ten percent get fired
every month every month where was that
ge capital
and what is that um it was general
electric um
corporate finance i've worked for those
guys so what do you do
i would lend people money or lend
companies money that would then go off
and use that money to lend to other
people so i ran the manchester cell
center office at
26 years of age and i just
you know indulge myself in that culture
of
success is possessional financial reward
um until i reached a point where i
really really didn't like myself anymore
i didn't like who i'd become
at that the pendulum of insecure
sad unmotivated scared little schoolboy
had become arrogant i am this i am that
i am the best i am look how successful i
am look at my numbers look at my sales
look at my car look at my houses or
house you know
they had gone the other way so i've gone
from being timid and frightened
to being an arrogant dick and then
suddenly i'm like yeah this is not cool
what was that point was this something
was there an incident was it compounding
over time
yeah that was um i was how's the best
way to phrase this
i was caught cheating i was not i was
not traditionally good
one-on-one boyfriend versus girlfriend
so i was messing around and getting
carried away with the
the life in london um
and then i decided that that wasn't the
right the way i wanted to live my life i
didn't want to be that individual
and i needed to change so i resigned
from ge
um i jumped on an airplane flew to egypt
um
and went to be a dive instructor for a
year completely get out of that
corporate
successful doggy dog world isn't it
interesting
how our behavior in relationships
often is like a distilled version of
other stuff that's going on it sometimes
identifies areas that we're not quite
going right in our life yeah
you you know i began to believe the hype
i began to believe my own [ __ ]
i began to believe that i was this rock
star of a salesperson and
you know all the things that or what you
perceive to be the glory that comes with
that
the bars the the clubs the women the the
cash
um and i had to break that mold and
that's what i did
and you know went and jumped under the
sea and went and played with nature and
got out of bed at five o'clock in the
morning grew my hair long
got in good shape again and
and got in touch with with nature and
diving in the red sea
so let's think about the sort of
different ways we've gone so you've gone
from like this
timid bullied bottom of the pile
to a very brash very
projecting overtly successful
top of the pile prick to now this kind
of monastic lifestyle very in touch with
nature very spiritual
so it's kind of bouncing around it's
different all part of the journey of
trying to find yourself you know
i hadn't i hadn't found myself then i
just realized that
i didn't want to be this timid schoolboy
that had then
catapulted itself into this wolf on wall
street
arrogant do whatever i want money
grabbing
individual and i didn't want to be that
guy um
so come as far away from that guy as i
can possibly be earn 600
a month as a dive instructor that's
couldn't be any further away
and that was all part of the process of
building the guy who i eventually would
become and i'm still on that journey and
i'll stop that journey when when my time
is done there will never ever be
the final version of me will just be a
continual path of
i've tried that i like that i'm going to
take that from it
that stuff i'm not going to take that's
that's not cool i'm going to leave that
there and then
you know i can't be a dive instructor
unfortunately it doesn't
it doesn't generate enough to look after
the family that that i want to look
after
but the idea of him some of the
mythologies of being a diving instructor
i quite like so i'm going to take those
now what i'm going to do i'm going to
get drunk in a bar one night and
invest in a nightclub take us there so
you've been diving for a while
yeah i've been here i've been attracted
by my plan was to be a dive instructor
for a year
figure my [ __ ] out and then decide what
i was going to do in um
egypt in the red sea why'd you choose my
father was building a
safari boat over there so that was an
easy gig
and randomly enough i mean that's
another journey of a story my father was
a sales and martin consultant for
35 years hit his 40th birthday and
decided he'd had enough and was gonna
sell up and go and build a diving safari
bill he's probably on a similar
similar thought process to me um so that
was an easy fit
um then i met a dutch guy called freck
um
around five o'clock in the morning i
must have told this story a thousand
times
agreed to lend him ten thousand dollars
to finish a beach club
and i got into the bar business at that
moment there and that took me that
completely you know i recircled back to
the the type of individual i was in ge
to a certain degree way more partying um
drank my ass off for 18 months and put
myself in a coma
and flatlined our operating table
three times um
and completely changed my life
take us through that 18 months
yeah a lot of fun a lot of fun i was
learning a completely new industry
um i brought a sales and marketing
thought process to a bar business in
egypt and there was lots of hotels
coming up i saw lots of opportunity
um i started to see a desire to work for
myself
that started to manifest itself in me
where um i'd learn
from these massive corporate
conglomerates like ge
and i wanted to be my own boss but i
didn't know what i wanted to be my own
boss in
um what a lifestyle you know waking up
every morning
a bit of a bit of a hangover go to the
office design a flyer on clipart
i'm not [ __ ] you that's how we did
it you know a poster in the toilet
advertising a band
you know that that was the that was how
we marketed our venues
and all these hotels were starting to
crop up you know how do we talk to the
hotel how do we get the guests out of
the hotel it was
it was that whole process in the daytime
and then at night time you know
8 30 and i would start drinking and we'd
finish it about six in the morning and
we'd go again and we go again and we'd
go again and
that just continued to go around and
around until
the um 27th of uh july when it all
stopped
what happened i woke up in the morning
my stomach
looked like the biggest piece of blue
cheese you've ever seen your life i look
nine months pregnant
i was 118 kilos which was what 20 odds
don't
um
[Music]
i'll show you some pictures so
then they took me to the hospital um
within 12 hours my lungs are collapsed i
was with in intensive care within a day
um i was given four days to live my
father had to
try and raise the money to get an air
ambulance and get me out of that country
the doctors have said we can't keep them
alive um
just not sufficiently sophisticated just
they couldn't deal with the [ __ ] that
was going on my lungs had collapsed i
had to collide
i was i was dying and i was dying fast
um you know i had acute pancreatitis
which has a
pretty much a 80 mortality rate
and i was i was deep on that process um
my dad managed to
convince for friends to lend him the
money
28 000 quid or 25 000 quid for a
air ambulance to get me home and
you know there was there was some
processes in that where i was very lucky
to get an air ambulance you know there's
not they're not sitting on runways
waiting to fly
idiots home that drank themselves into a
stupa
um but eventually you know the big man
looked after me i got managed to get on
an airplane
i was flown back into manchester
i was taken to leyton hospital and the
number one pancreatic surgeon on the
planet was in that hospital
um my dad finally got them to admit me
um and he promised to look after me and
try and save my life and
six months later i left artwork so you
go in
what's the operations what are the
procedures that need i don't know
i was in a coma that's right i've got no
clue induced or
medically induced to comey yes that was
i was put into that i think
on the 29th of july
and i woke up from that on my birthday
31st of august
and then went back to sleep again and
woke up again in um
um on the 9th of september
can you remember the journey 18 years
ago you remember the
flight from egypt were you induced
during that time
yeah i was gone i didn't from the moment
so the last memory i have
was being awake when they um banged a
12-inch metal spike into my ribs to give
me a lung puncture you still got the
skull yeah
yeah i was awake
that the worst pain of the no that was
the weirdest thing actually
it was like a red hot poker being shoved
into you but it meant i could breathe
so with that that that satisfaction i
couldn't talk
so you've got this this doctor coming
towards you with this thing and you're
like what the [ __ ] you gonna do with
that
what that's not good is it there's only
a few places that that can go and i
don't need to go in any of them yeah
exactly what what are you planning to do
with that
but you know there was nothing you know
both both lungs would
work were filled with fluid pancreas had
swelled up
lungs are filled with fluid and this
thing had to go into me or
or there was no oxygen going in so when
he banged it in
you know yeah it was uh that was a
moment unless you know you're alive
okay so you put into this medically
induced coma can you
take us through what happened next i um
woke up
in singapore um and i had a full-time
job
i got up in the morning lived in an
apartment similar to this in singapore
and can remember the colour of the
shower the registration plate on my car
the suits i used to work where to work
and i ran a sales team that sold virtual
reality games
and i did that for for two years how
fine are the memories how fine-grained
are the memories from that time yeah i
can remember the spelling that was on
your top if i went to dinner with you
that night
the most not like not like a holiday
when you were 14
no like a significant career that you
had
in your life what do you think is
happening there
is this common for people that are
induced comas to live another life yeah
look you have to have a load of
psychiatric treatment when you come out
of a coma they have to um
they have to help you through that
process you know i went to sleep with
hair shorter than yours
and i woke up with hair longer than mine
i mean seriously i bite my nails
i woke up with things like that like one
of those uh instagram girls
um so yeah i uh i had to have some
treatment and you know you asked the
questions
what the hell was that i'm still not
sure today that
and you know we can get into some really
deep rabbit
holes on that one whether that was
something else
or whether that was simply my mind
keeping me
super busy while the doctors had the
chance to fix me
you know it's four months just under
four months i was away so you know
that's the days i see a lot of time
and how long did it feel being that two
years so you were
working a job yes selling people's
memories no vr no what this vr was was i
could buy your life
so i would go and buy your life story
and i would
plug it in i'd put the headset i'd go
into this pod and i would wake up in the
morning i would be you
and whatever you do i would do and i
would live your life
so you could buy muhammad ali you could
buy mike tyson you could buy pele you
could buy
out i don't even think realtor was out
so you could buy famous people's lives
and then you would go into a virtual
reality experience
come into his life or her life and then
he would live their life
and we were testing the latest version
of this software and i was the kid who
tested it
um and it got blocked and locked and i
got
taken into this black room plastic
membrane
i spent six months in this room trying
to find my way out
and as i went into that room the
computer software people were talking to
me
um don't worry we'll patch it we'll fix
it it's
you know i'm just stuck in this black
space i can't find i can
kind of feel the size but i couldn't
find the edges if you know what i mean
it was like a black membrane
um and then slowly over time
their conversations changed from talking
me through the code that they were going
to fix they were going to change
to telling me the sports results and
talking to me about what's happening in
the news
i started to realize that
the only way i was going to get out of
this room was if i got my out these
people these programmers were not going
to get me out of this room it was going
to be me
and what i know now is it was not
computer programmers
it was my parents and my family and my
friends around my hospital bed
just talking to me you know my dad sat
there every single day
reading the newspaper to me reading
sports results
in my virtual world this was the
computer programmers losing faith that
they could fix this problem
and i'd be stuck here forever and i
started to realize that the only way i
was going to get out of this was if i
started to get out of it if i found a
way
so instead of sleeping all day in this
room i was awake and i was looking i was
picking i was trying to find
some way of breaking through this
membrane and then after six months of
picking away
i eventually got a finger through and
another finger through and then i
open this member and stick my head out
and i woke up in the hospital bed on my
birthday my entire family were
and that was me
it sounds unbelievable i've heard the
story before but it sounds
insane it sounds like some
inception i i see it look have you seen
the matrix
so i saw it like that that's how i sort
of kind of
put some place to it after you know you
come out of that [ __ ] and you
lose four months of your life you know i
did i did
i've lost chunks of my life for
different purpo for different reasons
whether it was
having to stay in a one-star hotel hotel
enforced for a while or whether it was a
bit of time that we we spent in a cairo
uh facility
so i've lost chunks of my life and i've
had to learn to deal with those chunks
and
some of them were because my own stupid
actions in my younger life
um and some of them were for things that
were not my fault
this was my fault i drank myself into
that position i put myself in
in real harm's way but i massively
believe that it was a wake-up call that
i
talk about regularly today of you know
[ __ ] adversity it happens what do we do
with that and how do we use that to fuel
the person that we become
that's the powerful stuff there was a
reason i went through that experience
there's a reason i watched them
operate on me and take it all out
somebody was showing me
that i screwed my life up so badly
that i shouldn't wake up and that should
be the end of it and i'm gonna make you
watch it
but actually i'm going to make you wake
up i'm actually going to give you
another chance
do not [ __ ] it up again that's why it
was so
clear to me that i was awake during that
entire coma while i was given an
experience like i was given why i buried
my father in my dream he died and we had
to go through that whole thing and i can
i remember crying my family remember
me in the coma crying weeping in real
life [ __ ] breaking down that was at
my father's funeral
you know my family remembered me waking
up and sort of on my birthday and
sort of looking at the end of the bed
and there was my dad and i kind of
looked at everybody
and i just stared at him like you
shouldn't be here because it was so
real that i'd lost him in my dream in my
virtual world in my job in singapore
he'd gone
is dad still here now yeah yeah asian
england but
he's all around how do you think you'll
feel inevitably at some point you are
going to have to say goodbye to him
twice
that's a pain that no one really should
go through demolish me
well that will be the toughest thing
i've ever had to go through
like i would imagine with 95 of the
children that wore this planet
yeah but you had to do it twice
yeah i did kind of um
it was and still is today an incredibly
powerful experience that keeps me true
to being the person i want to be
you know when there's when there's
moments where i have doubt i have
questions and you know
covered at the moment in the situation
that we're all faced with this this
incredible thing that's happened to the
world in the last
eight or nine months you know i always
look back to that
point in my life where i was able to
come through that and i was able to gain
so much from it i just have to
i have to think about this as the same
forethought process
there is a reason why this is happening
every single road we ever go down
no matter how painful it is there is a
purpose to that road
why have we been presented with it why
are we going to go down it and why are
we going to come out the other side of
it
the key to paul evans today and who i've
become
is finding the purpose of all of those
adverse roads whatever they are
whatever the reason is there's a reason
i have to deal with that
what am i going to learn from it how can
i use that and then how can i pass that
knowledge on to others
what did you learn from being in that
other than stop drinking
that i had a greater purpose in life and
the purpose was not me it was others
if i made my journey about everyone else
then by default my journey would become
so enlightening when it's only about me
it's selfish it's self-centered it's
egotistical then it's worthless really
what are you doing it for today i have
two children and every white children
prior to that
they are my absolute everything i have a
team of
500 people today if i make the journey
about them and their path and their
career and their growth and their
redevelopment and their
becoming the best version of themselves
if i have 500 people
suddenly becoming better than they were
yesterday and i'm
fortunate enough to sit with those
people their power and their energy
will drive me to become wow
where's that that's limitless and that
was the big change that the comab did
for me it made me
understand it's nothing to do with me
it's about everyone else
and if i have been given a second chance
to project that message and to help that
then by default my life is going to be
absolutely amazing
because i'm 500 600 800 000 2 000 10 000
12
000. why
after being in the coma did you go back
into nightlife
with these insights i because it became
it became a business not a lifestyle i
didn't realize that at the time
i didn't invest in the nightclub because
i wanted to be an owner or a business
owner
or a mentor or a ceo eventually
i wanted to have a bit of a riot i would
have a bit of fun i wanted to be
excitable
understand that it was the glory hunter
you know in our industry today and
you're in our industry
there are two types of guy that operate
in the food and beverage industry
there's guys like me who love
what we do and there's guys that love
the glory of what we think we do
there's a guy who stands in an office
and talks to his team and helps develop
and grow them
and there's a guy who sits on the table
with a bottle of belvedere and
everything that sits around him my
equivalent insight from 14 years of
running nightclubs
is that some people realize that you can
quickly acquire capital and have
influence in a
quite low barrier to entry uh industry
industry yeah um
and other people love to drink and party
and realize they can monetize it yeah
and professional party boys will
they're able to move fast and break
things very quickly which is impressive
and if you can weaponize them as a good
businessman they're incredibly powerful
yep but there's a glass ceiling on how
much they can scale
because there's only one of them and
they can only drink so much and
there's a lifespan on it like the the
promoter that you know that's
still doing it at 30 years old 35 years
old
it's a depreciating asset that person
by health coma uh
wife family lack of energy just
sheer demotivation is on that trajectory
it's scalable
to do it the way that you have spoken
about that well we've had those guys
that work for us and they've been
incredibly valuable for us
they still need them right they're your
f they're your foot shot they're not the
foot soldiers they're the sas operatives
that you send in
i think the end i think the industry is
changing especially when you
you have a scalable business i think
you've got one venue
you can have the guy who sits on the
table and invites whoever he invites to
come and have a drink with him
when you have a multi-site multi-purpose
multi-location
global desire then you have to have a
strategy at the top of how that
guy on the table becomes the digital way
of advertising the consumer
and in all honesty you use a great
terminology
you weaponize them weapons explode and
you can't use them again
true absolutely yeah push the button
bang there's my impact i need another
one yeah thank you can someone send in
the replacement i can't keep doing that
to these
28 year old kids because i was the 28
year old kid
and that ruined me how did you or it
made me
one or the other how did you reintegrate
after this experience
because you've been how do you bench
press now uh
140 kilos wow right at my peak i was 120
and i'm banging them out
and then i went into my coma and then i
became this so
from 120 kilos to 70 kilos
right you could put your hand around my
around my leg
i couldn't even lift a bar i never mind
120 140.
[Music]
i just became this little timid mouse of
vulnerability and
and and [ __ ] i break
i didn't realize i broke you know i was
like every
25 year old kid i mean destructive one
was hold you at this point
29 right 29.
so all of a sudden you realize you can
get sick you can get ill you you're not
indestructible you need to be careful
how you treat your body
you know no 15 year old kid today is
running around thinking i get hurt
you don't give a [ __ ] he doesn't he'll
jump off you know he'll jump off a
multi-storey car park because he had a
few too many beers because he doesn't
care you're made of rubber
amazing rubber aren't you rubber and
magic yeah exactly and
so all of a sudden i realized that you
know i can break and if i don't take
care of myself and
um be careful how i move forward then
i could have a problem on the flip side
the birds were singing everything
smelled beautiful and the sun was
shining
it was the most humble
embracing part of my entire life i've
never been more
thankful even now today with all the
wonderful
people i have around me that year of
feeling insecure and feeling vulnerable
and feeling broken but also feeling like
wow i've got a second chance
and i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna maximize
that to the absolute
most sort of help me through that
process of feeling vulnerable and
gradually rebuilding myself and probably
realizing that actually i don't need to
lift 120 kilos and
i don't need to stand on the door and
stop people coming in
there's somebody bigger and stronger
than me you you can do that
i'll stand behind you and train you so
you never have to stop people coming in
and it was just that that gradual
process of believing
wow i have a second chance and that's
the most powerful thing in the world
that's that's probably the most powerful
thing that's ever ever happened to me
that
absolute feeling of this is your second
chance
do something good and how's that
impacted beyond wanting to serve and
facilitate other people
how's that impacted the way that you
live your day-to-day life or see
day-to-day life
um the stuff doesn't matter so whatever
that stuff may be the flash car the big
house the
fancy watch i don't care about it i'm
not interested in it
it's a byproduct of doing what i love
well
um i really value relationships today
i have so many people in my life that
um really really mean something you know
you talk about having friends that you
can count on one hand
i'm blessed to have people i can count
on two hands because i you know i put a
lot of time and effort into
into relationships and having real
purposeful relationships not like that
before
not as much as i am now you know ever i
have a i have a partner in my life
dom who is you know my absolute soul
mate it took me a long time to find that
level of person where i
i believed in a certain level of
relationship
and how enhancing your partner makes you
a better version of yourself
there's so many people today that run
around relationships destabilizing their
partner because they're afraid that
they're going to leave them or you know
if i'm if if i pick them up too much
they'll leave me
so i'll just keep them on balance i also
used to be that guy
where today i want that person on the
absolute
mountain of this world because they pick
me
and if i can put them there whoever that
may be my best friend my girlfriend my
children
make them feel amazing the fact that
they choose to spend time with me by
default makes me feel amazing because if
they're so amazing and they want to hang
out with me i must be so amazing
so so that was a was a big step of how i
evolved my
outside of work activity you know i do a
lot of
i do a lot of diving today i do a lot of
experience stuff
that you know success if you like as
everyone else perceives it
allows you in my opinion the facility to
do the stuff
that's good stuff that's wholesome stuff
that i get to live in dubai
this amazing country that gives you
limitless opportunities
and if you give to dubai it will give
you back what you give it
and i talked about this a long time ago
put my foundations here this is my home
this is where i'm going to live
i'm going to dedicate myself to this
place device says thank you
there you go there's your opportunity
there's no jealousy here there's no
or i don't you know i don't get to see a
lot of that i only see
people being encouraged to do well you
don't hear about people key in cars in
dubai
if you have a lamborghini in england
someone's going to key it
isn't happening somebody goes well falls
back
well nick's let me into this apartment
to record just by leaving the door open
yeah man and i i couldn't believe it
this is really expensive and
and it's you know it's right in the
marina and he was like no
mate you don't understand like this is
dubai this is dubai what a beautiful
statement
yeah we are safe proper safe well great
place to bring up a family what a great
place to ring of chilean i was blessed
that
that my both my children had a good six
years seven years here
so moving forward now you come back you
do your recovery you start to grow an
awful lot of venues 18 venues or
something in in 18 months something like
that uh no a bit longer than that but i
think we overall we did
we probably did 20 there was when i went
into the coma there was three
we had three venues um by the end how
did they perform while you were in
don't know actually i never really asked
that question just let everyone get on
with it that could have been the first
thing that you've done if my business
partner went into a coma
the first thing that he would do would
be show me the excel sheet i want to see
the balance yeah
that's probably a bit stronger than i
was i don't think i was worried too much
about that i think
um yeah it was um i let them just get on
and do what they had to do everybody
stepped up and did what and look i was
not the only owner
i've i've been blessed to be in a
partnership since since day one on this
process and
you know i have a i have a great team of
people that take care of
obviously they took care of stuff when i
was in a coma and even today you know we
we're we're going through some very
challenging moments now i'm not around
all the time
i have a team of people who look after
it so i guess they did okay i managed to
come out of it so
in the end we had um we built i think we
built about 25 across egypt over a
eight to nine year period what separates
you and your particular working process
that's a non-typical result
right that's not what most even the best
of the best promoters don't tend to have
that much aggressive growth
what is it that you're doing that's
causing that to occur
if i don't keep building this business
there's no opportunity for the people
who are in this business
everybody wants growth everybody wants
to become that i believe or i try to
grow an environment where everybody
wants to become the best version of
themselves so
i have a responsibility to all of those
people to provide them with the next
opportunity
not you or not somebody else or not one
of the different operators in this city
it's my job to make sure that you're you
as a bartender
has got the opportunity to become a bar
manager and you as a bar manager i've
got the opportunity to become a floor
manager and use a floor and
so that appetite of the team that i'm
trying to build to become the best
version of themselves
drives me every day to get out there and
go and find the next
opportunity so by default that
energy that they push me to create more
opportunities gives me the opportunity
to do what i love
and i love to build whatever that may be
build you
build a team build my children build a
sun build a house build a tree housing
lockdown
whatever it may be i just love to build
stuff i love to create something
i talk about you know whatever you're
doing you should be building
something i don't mean you should build
a bar
it should be building you you and a
family whether it may be
somebody something growth is a fabulous
thing in the air
you know we today have what however many
venues we've got every single one of
those
general managers that runs the show
started
at least two positions lower some of
them started in three or four positions
that's that's the cool [ __ ] you know
i've got 26 year old gm's
in any other business on the planet
there shouldn't be gm's [ __ ] up here i
i push them and i let them make mistakes
i want them to make mistakes because
i want to learn i want to grow and they
drive me you know the second i hear one
of my gm's is looking at somewhere else
i'm like right where can i move that kid
i put years into that boy i'm not losing
it i need to find something else so
in covid when the rest of the world is
is sort of
what we're going to do i'm out there
looking for opportunities so we're we're
going to do
five more as it sits today and i'll
probably find a little couple over the
next few months
so when the world wakes up again we've
got some footprint and it was the same
in egypt
great opportunity great brands great
reputation um
and it's exciting stuff no one likes to
do the same stuff every day and every
deal that you do
is slightly different the negotiation is
different the personnel are different
the project's different the venue's
different the demographic's different
the consumer is different it's
it's variety that keeps me engaged
take us through what happened toward
leaving egypt towards the back end you
had some more adventures there
yeah we did and i got involved um in a
huge marina development and where i was
asked to come in and do the sales and
the marketing and the leasing
and every opportunity that came with
that and i grabbed all of it with
everything i had
we built this marina rented out 140 odd
shops
built 10 of our own did all the sales
all the marketing all the entertainment
launched the opening weekend with like
50 000 visitors
biggest tourist attraction outside of
the pyramids it was
amazing because we did it so bloody fast
certain things got forgotten along the
journey and one of which was permits
so i get a phone call from my company gm
at the time saying
um can i um can i take i need to take
some money to cairo
and pay for the license for one of your
venues i said yeah of course you can how
much is it he said it's three grand for
the for the guy the ministry of tourism
i said okay cool take it from the safe
and that call was recorded
um and that was apparently a bribery
case
so internal affairs started um needed me
um i'm like well i haven't done anything
he said well you bribed a government
official i didn't bribe anyone
i just said yes to my g i'm asking me
for money
uh would you need to come to cairo and
admit that you were the beneficiary
that's right no problem i'll do that
bring your passport on a toothbrush
why would i need a toothbrush for we
have to go in jail for four days
i'm not going to eat jail for four days
but you have to do that so it works
we'll we'll arrest you
you'll say you did it and then we'll
release you am i no chance i'm a dad and
i'm diabetic you're not putting me in a
cairo jail for four days
um so the guy said well then we'll come
and get you and
because i was pretty well connected in
that country i was i mean
i won't go into that level of detail but
there was not a lot i couldn't have got
solved in that country
so i said then come and get me knock
yourself out
so we did so i went on the run and um
rang all my friends and all my
powerful people in that country to say
look i need to solve this problem
every one of them was saying this is
[ __ ] it's ridiculous um
we'll fix it for you just stay out of
the way so everyone gave me the keys to
different apartments around egypt and i
spent four months
avoiding being grabbed hiding in
alleyways and
waking up in the middle of the night
because they were coming for me so
what's the closest call you had
three o'clock in the morning they know
where you are get out of bed go now
throw all your films i was working with
i had burners and everything man
brilliant yeah i'd watch the james bond
movie thought i'd get away with it you
know it's done
well i thought i knew i was done those
lads are smart way smarter than i
thought they were
um so in the end um some do grasp me up
so i was some [ __ ] story um we know
the judge who's going to try the case
he'd become an interview
if you come and tell your story to him
give him your passport he'll release you
into his custody and you don't have to
go into a jail i'm like all right cool
i'll do that
uh walked into this room um and as i
walked in it was just him signing his
own
oh my [ __ ] and then bang in they came
mp5
threw me in the back of a van and then
proper abused me for a while to to
remind you well that would remind me of
i'm just a british kid and we won't have
that arrogance
um and then i got thrown in a cairo jail
which was um
an extremely unpleasant experience how
long for
i did 12 days in the the
darkest places you can imagine
are there many jails in cairo just one i
don't know
i only saw one i only saw one yeah not
um
not something i would wish on my worst
enemy that's probably like that lawless
inside
yeah pretty much yeah pretty much
you've read about it in the book um so
then eventually my my biggest friend in
egypt and in the book he's known as mbf
my big friend
uh flew in um and intervened met the
uh head of the district attorney and
said
what's going on why do you need this kid
what what what's the what's the big
situation
and it turned out that the guy who was
after me
it was his brother who was the guy in
the ministry of tourism
and he didn't want him prosecuting so
the minute he could get older me
his brother because his brother was
arrested so the minute i was grabbed the
case could be done
lost and his brother could go out and
that's why he had such a hard on for me
what happened to his brother in the end
the whole case disappeared there was no
no charges nothing my general manager
spent four months in jail
i was away from my family for four
months i had the most horrific
experience of my entire life in that
cairo jail
um and there was no consequence to
anybody whatsoever
that was the end of it so then i decided
it was probably a good time
to leave that country i'd lost faith
there i was uh that really upset me i'd
given so much to that country
you know at one point we applied we
employed over a thousand people
you know and i worked so hard to do
great stuff in that country
i gave it way more than it gave me and i
felt betrayed
i hadn't done anything wrong the way i
was treated was bang out of order
i was a good person that i was doing
good things in that country i was
introducing nightlife i was the first
guy to bring
house music into egypt i you know we
brought the ministry of sound we brought
head candy
we were doing some really cool stuff and
we're doing it properly we're doing it
right
and that was just a shitty experience so
i kind of said to myself you know i'm
i don't really want a beer anymore i
don't feel safe any longer and once you
don't feel safe somewhere that's a scary
place to be
um but then bam revolution happened so
then we didn't really get a chance to
plan our exit or
strategize how we were going to move
18th of january everybody went into the
streets and started protesting against
the president
and seven days later i'd lost 85 percent
of my business
and i was done that was the end of it it
became
uh how would you say kind of repatriated
private businesses became just
repatriated towards
the government right people just came
and took businesses and then they
released criminals into the street and
stuff
they opened every single uh prison
and we had we had i remember one night
when i'd managed to get all of the um
all of the foreign workers that
employees team members that we had
to my villa and we fueled a boat that
sat off shore
and we had you know makeshift weapons
because there was a bunch of prisoners
coming
to our compound to basically rape and
loot
and we'd heard about this it had hit
that coastal
that compounded it that when it only
come in two hours and
we're sitting there with [ __ ]
baseball bats waiting for to protect our
homes i mean that was the most
frightening 40 hours of my life
was there was two revolutions is that
right was yeah yeah
how did that work so they they
they didn't like the existing um
government
and so he stood down and that panned out
the way it did and then in came the
muslim brotherhood
um and they didn't like that so they
went back and did it again and
they went back and the bar was gone by
then i was gone so i left everything
what we had you know we come from we had
18 operating places
in january and by february we had six
that was it it was over i moved here
with 20 000
and we we had a business that was doing
millions still in a month half a million
it was gone it was done and then you
arrived in dubai yep arrived in dubai
and um
bought and sold cars onto bizzle for 18
months to
put my kids through school and pay the
rent and convince
um some investors to back me in a
in a bar play and eventually in 213
i managed to convince a consortium of
individuals to lend me some money
and i built q43 and that was it
the journey began then you know then we
spent the next six years
we've done 14 venues 15 venues now um
it's been incredible absolutely i
couldn't have i couldn't have wished it
in my wildest dreams it would have been
as
um enjoyable and successful and fruitful
as it has been
happier in dubai than you were happiest
in egypt happier and happier today than
i've ever been in my entire life
even in covert this is the happiest i've
ever been and tomorrow
i'll be a little bit more happy what's
that built around other than
serving other people the ability to deal
with the ability to know that you can
come through pretty much anything
we talked about this off off the camera
that
unchosen adversity is actually one of
the greatest gifts you'll ever be given
the the real understanding of what the
body can deal with when it has to deal
with it
what the mind can deal with when it has
to you know you touched on a
you know whether it's a triathlete or a
ultra marathon runner
who chooses to take himself in deep
water the reward at the end of that is
amazing you know i chose to do an ultra
marathon
speaking in the third person i can't do
it for ultraman i have no desire to do
an alternative
um and at the end of it you've done it
wow boom
amazing but you chose to go there
you chose to put yourself through that
and you choose to feel the reward of
that
when something happens to you that
absolutely
slaps you at the side of the head and is
relentless in its pursuit of demolishing
you
and you're able to come through it
the foundations and the strength of that
gives you
to overcome whatever this globe is going
to throw at you
and believe me now your ankle is not the
only [ __ ] that's coming your way
your ankle will show you i can deal with
the [ __ ] i never thought i could so
whatever you're going to give me
i believe today whatever you're going to
give me is just a puzzle
i need to start fixing you know i have
not and this sounds
and i mean this in the most humble of
manners i've not flinched once in
not once not once have i sat there and
gone
oh my god how am i gonna no
hmm this is the chance for me to prove
how good i really am
i think i might be very good at this bar
business malarkey
now's my chance to prove it because when
it's easy and they're just all walking
in
yeah it doesn't need a guy like me to
run it any one of us can run it
these are the moments when you get the
opportunity to really shine
how do i navigate through the most
challenging food and beverage
marketplace ever and when i do
wow look at the version that's going to
come at the end of that
that's how i see it and i was able i'm
able to see that
because of all the other [ __ ] you know
as i'm hiding in a
alleyway in cairo thinking [ __ ] what's
gonna happen to me
nothing really okay what happened was
horrific
but i'm still able to sit in your
beautiful apartment and you're
you are talk to me about it so what came
of it i became more interesting
i became more able to help individuals
come through that [ __ ]
because i've proved it i've come through
it and that i am
the the living sleeping breathing proof
that a 13 year old boy who's never going
to do anything in his life
can become a guy today that you reach
out to and say hey listen should we chew
the fat a little bit
wow with too much caffeine in us a
couple of things i've got in my mind
first one being my newsletter that i
part of this week
i was spending some time with ultra
endurance athletes
and one of the realizations that i got
was that
this is why you're here is a very good
sense to tell yourself when things get
challenging
we can start to flinch
and turn away when discomfort comes in
right discomfort naturally is
uncomfortable
but that discomfort is a sign of growth
whether it's building a relationship
building a business
learning a new skill in the gym whatever
it might be
the discomfort is a feature not a bug
that is the reason that we're doing the
thing that we're here for so lean into
it
because the time is going to pass in any
case so you might as well spend it well
so that's one of the the lessons i'll
certainly be taking away from dubai
that there are i spoke to marcus smith a
guy who hit a wall at 54 kilometers an
hour
snapped seven ribs punctured a lung and
ripped his scapular off and had to focus
on just keeping himself alive by
breathing
until he got picked up by an ambulance
three hours later and then ran for the
shake
last year 30 marathons in 30 days like
hearing people who go through that level
of adversity we were talking
before we started about how brilliant it
would be for everybody
if there was an inverted instagram where
instead of seeing the best of everyone's
lives you get to see the worst
what is what is the absolute worst
scenario that you can imagine
a person who lives
some weird form of like panic room
torture inception movie with
their father dying and then wakes up
having lost a third of their body weight
and then you know like that that's a
story that people need to hear and i
think that contrasting effect is so
important
the other thing that i've got in my mind
is especially
this year all of our problems in the
21st century are problems of abundance
and not scarcity we have too much
stimulus we have too much convenience we
have too much food
and what that leads to is people
who are inexperienced with adversity
inexperienced with discomfort one of the
reasons why sports like crossfit and
ultra endurance races
have an attraction is that it gives
people the opportunity to do that
but i think that this for a lot of
people especially in the west
covid will be the first real adversity
they've ever faced
my friend asked me a couple about
probably about a year ago
he said when was the last time you
failed at doing something
and i was like bro i
i really don't know like i haven't
failed
up until about 30 years stuff
hadn't gone perfectly and there would
have been businesses that started that
kind of fizzled out or whatever
but no big catastrophes no major
failures
and he was like man i i think that you
are missing out on valuable learning
opportunities
i don't know how you can make yourself
fail but there is something to be
learned through failure
[Music]
and this year
for a lot of people will be their first
experience of failure now i've happened
to get a double hit of it in the i've
experienced covid
and ruptured my achilles during covet
which is okay like that's two things but
very quickly when that happened
especially with the achilles left so
with kovid i
dealt with that fairly easily i was so
surprised
at the resilience and the fortitude that
my system was able to
create that i didn't even know was there
it's like opening a door
inside of a house i'd lived in my entire
life to a room that i didn't even know
existed
and that was very a very very
interesting experience
and i wonder i
i wonder how many people can reframe the
experience of 2020
in a way that makes them better than if
it hadn't happened
that brings them closer together with
their family that's the key
the key is to take from this what it's
giving you you know
you talk about failure um you know when
was the last time you failed it's a
fabulous question
i've never failed i'm still practicing
you only fail when you quit and if you
go back at it again then you remove the
failure
so i'm not i'm gonna do i'm gonna i'm
gonna learn to run a mountain right
and off i go training marathon train
train to entertain train and i get to 17
kilometers and i quit
right then i've quit then i failed
and until i start that journey again i
still have the failure ticked
the second i go i'm not having that and
i start again i've just rubbed out
failure
not failed because i'm still at it i'm
still going
and at some point in my life i'll run
that marathon i never ever failed
i've had bars that didn't work could be
considered failures
i consider them to be educational
messages to make sure i never build a
bar like that again
i'll fail i don't need to fail what i
need to do
is figure out the solution to what's put
in front of us i think
you know one of the biggest messages of
people that
have platforms that are growing like
your good self
is the ability for people and why people
are watching it because they want to get
hope
they want to get they want to get
answers to questions they don't have
you know so many people are asking when
is this thing over
i'm not asking that i can't control that
so why focus on it what i can control is
what i do in the moment
i'm not chasing down that vaccine how
can i possibly
possibly make a difference to a vaccine
process
i might be able to sell if you ever want
to get it but don't focus on the end of
it
you're in the middle of it focus on now
how are you going to deal with the now
don't focus on when am i going to come
out of it we all want to come out of it
we all want it to be over
but we let the people who are busy with
that be busy with it
you'd be busy with what you can control
you won't hear me asking the question no
[ __ ] i can't wait till this thing's over
that's so obvious because we all want to
go back to normal
quite not that impressed by normal
i'm not that impressed by instant
gratification
ernie i have that challenge with my
children you know
[Music]
they want it so easy i had to fight
with every tooth and nail to get to
where i am today
and i've enjoyed that process today
we knock on a door of our neighbor and
we go what do you think
and if the neighbor goes what are you
talking about
well it's just instagram really it's the
same thing
but i just want that personal
interaction because
this photo of me and this t-shirt only
got 127 likes
this one got 100 200 500 whatever the
number may be when i was a kid
it's the same as knocking on your
neighbor's door and going what do you
think
in everything you're lunatic in today's
world we want the now
we're not prepared to do the graft kobit
is the graft
this is the world showing us the
universe showing us ain't meant to be
easy mate it's meant to be hard
because if you work at it and it's hard
it has a value
easy money easy [ __ ] you know easy go you
you go and gamble
you put 500 on red and it comes up and
you win a grand
you're gonna spun the ground on a pair
of shoes because you just won it you
wouldn't have bought a grand
grand shoes prior to winning it if
you've earned that thousand
it has a value and i've said that from
our bar business be busy with the guy
who spends the 50 dirham on a pint
because he earns his money
and it means something to him so say
thank you to him
the guy who comes and spends a million
dirhams on a certain check at the moment
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about you he's
got no loyalty to you whatsoever he's
got no value to money
don't be busy with him be busy with the
normal man that understands how hard it
is to earn that money
because he'll be your guys in your bar
four times a week he's your guy who
comes to you and covered
because he remembers what you were like
in the good days the dude's spending a
million
he didn't give a [ __ ] about money he
doesn't know it never he's got no
comprehension of what it takes to earn a
million dirhams that's why he's prepared
to spunk it on a check
it's disgusting be after the guy that's
burnt it kovid should teach us all
let's earn it a little bit whatever it
may be earn the right
to run the triathlon earn the right to
run the marathon earn the right
to go from fifty thousand to seventy
thousand to ninety thousand or hundred
thousand followers
you've earned it i asked you how many
shows you did at the beginning of this
two and a half thousand shows 250.
250 shows
how many hours is that
plus research plus reaching out plus
convincing someone to come on the show
plus the editing
you have grafted to get 80 000 92 000
whatever the number may be
you've earned it so it feels like you've
been giving it feels like you got it you
didn't go and buy 90 000 followers did
you
no you went crafted you weren't earning
it so that would be
my message to anybody who's looking to
what can you take from
from this covet experience take the fact
that it's not
actually meant to be easy it's meant to
be tough
because tough is worth something one of
the concerns that i have
especially with covid that's been
weaponized by social media i've seen it
increasingly with
my dad with all of my friends anyone
that posted on facebook less so on
twitter but facebook seems to be the
social media of choice for speculation
in 2020 you know what i mean
and i worry about how much people are
externalizing their locus of control
so our locus of control should always be
as close to ourselves as possible
so you have social media which
prioritizes
socialized metrics of success this is
something that you can see
easily it's outward facing yeah there's
no chart above your head
where i can see your peace level or your
happiness level there's no happiness
counter
and sadly i worry
that the primary impact
kovit has had on people are those
socialized metrics of success
the 25 year old 30 year old 35 year old
guy or girl
who harnessed a lot of their self-worth
from being in the right place with the
right people with the right car with the
right shoes
with the right friends the right follow
account on instagram now no longer can
use that
they've had to focus if they pivot
correctly
on internal measures of success because
you're not scared of [ __ ] are you
that our world today genuinely values
that level of matrix as a barometer of
success
so famous for being famous i don't like
it i've got strong
opinions about it um but
status signaling has been around for
millions of years in biology and the
fact that it's now being weaponized
and being given a metric by some
companies like
twitter instagram and facebook
yes the war for our dopamine
and our ability to see what's truly
going on
has the power of the weapons has
swayed now away from us and that locus
of control is outside a little bit more
but the game's the same when your 14
year old girl says dad can i have an
instagram account what are you going to
tell her
no no
the only other industry the only other
industry that causes
their customers users are drug dealers
and social media is that one
we both do in the same documentary yes
so tristan is
so right tristan harris the guy that's
on that i've been a fan of him for three
years tristan if you're listening answer
my emails please mate
um i've been a fan of him for three
years and i went
deep deep deep down the rabbit hole
within a long time ago
and the other insight which i thought
was really really interesting from that
was looking at how
uh steve jobs didn't let his kids have
an ipad
what does that say
it says everything that says nothing
yeah says it's a great bit of a pr tool
it's a great story from the from a man
who's
you know probably one of the greatest
corporate leaders of our generation at
least
like him loathing you've got to respect
him um
it's a great story whether his kids have
life hands or not he'll ever know
you don't we don't know any we know what
people want us to know you know
um my son has an instagram account he's
not posted a single thing
why is he busy with instagram it's the
route
to the quickest success ray of what he's
busy with at the moment
he doesn't give a [ __ ] whether he gets
likes or not likes he's not in it for
that
he's in it to see pretty little girls
dressed up looking nice because he's a
15 year old kid full of testosterone
i get it um the second he starts posting
and then he starts changing the type of
post that you post to see the level
and then that's when dad will step in
and say listen mates i did it for a
purpose i'm in an industry where
fortunately all unfortunately it's a
requirement of what we do
um and but i know what it is i i don't
count likes i'm not bothered by it
doesn't matter to me
um but i did count followers because
the more followers the bigger the
message the louder the message the more
you know when i woke up the book and can
get out there and help people
i will not make a single pound out when
i woke up
but i've made so much from personal
growth of
first of all going through the
experience of writing it and
going deep in those
inner dark moments that i had to go
through to become who i was and then to
tell people that you know that is some
enlightening [ __ ]
for example i won't dance on the stage
because i'm petrified of people laughing
at me
from when i was 13 called up in a ball
being kicked in a playground
um i still won't dance because i can't
stand the thought process that you laugh
at me
because the echoes of the children
laughing at me when i couldn't spell
library
still ring through in my head the
ability to release that
was something i was never prepared to do
i'm going to keep that inside of me
that's that's my
demon when i released it into a book
eventually
i was like wow that's wow that's amazing
show my vulnerability show my me i'm not
this hard dude covering toes i'm
actually i cry i cut i bleed i'm a
normal
decent human being
that was a process that i went through
everybody that reads the book
and writes me one comment is worth way
more than any money i'll ever make out
that book
way way more so i needed a following i
needed people to listen so i could
help that was my thought process on it
i've kind of backed off that
in kobe i went completely away from it
the only thing i shared during covid was
the little projects of the things i was
building with the kids in
in the in the garden but
an interesting thought process that you
wouldn't let your 14 year old girl going
would you let your 15 year old boy go on
it
so yes probably probably 15 to 16 i
think would be the line
and it would be older for girls and it
would be for boys there's some
interesting insights
from the coddling of the american mind
by jonathan hate and
any parents or fledgling parents with
teenage children should probably
consider reading it
and it looks at um stats to do with
depression anxiety
etc you can tally the line
to when instagram became popular
and you just see a hockey stick
of an increase in anxiety and
depression self-harm and
one of the reasons that they give is
that
boys or males tend to fix problems
with physical violence which isn't
facilitated by social media
so you might call someone out on social
media have a
rubbish scrap at school with them the
next day shake hands and be best mates
whereas girls tend to enact violence
more verbally
and that is weaponized by social media
so yeah i think
there is definitely a lot that we still
need to kind of work out and erring on
the side of caution
probably seems like a smart way to go
man thank you so much for today people
want to check out your stuff
where should they go um paul john evs i
think it's my instagram
uh website when i woke up dot com
everything will be linked in the show
notes below including the fantastic when
i woke up the book
thank you man
you